at ball Arena
LeBron James and the Lakers first round
they won game one in Memphis
second round game one victorious in San
Francisco can they do it again this
place is a tough place to win
[Applause]
and right now the shot clocks like the
good old days are in the corners the
ones above the basket just about 15
minutes ago the start of the malfunction
they're still working on it but for now
they're in the corners
Mark as a player how much more difficult
is that
old school because I grew up in CYO days
when we had a shot clock exactly there
these guys grew up in gyms that had the
shot clock and the scores for on the
wall so it's a different adjustment for
them
and Mike a lot of them
look to the opposite
as the clock winds down
[Applause]
this is going to be a big change I
remember in 1999 we were playing in the
NBA finals against San Antonio and the
entire game five was played with the
shot clocks
on the ground and it was a lot different
sometimes it's hard to fix they're
working on it right now as we get set
for this matchup let's check in with
Lisa hey Mike the issues with the game
clock down at the Nuggets end of the
floor the fours apparently look like the
lower H and the twos look like nines so
they're going to start the game with
both game clocks off like you said using
the clocks on the floor old school I
have that problem until I got glasses
but I tell you I would rather play if
it's not the shot clock in the first
couple quarters I'd rather play with the
time
game time being a little bit off but
being able to look at the shot clock in
the normal place that's a good point